where is the top of the atmosphere this
is a question without a simple answer
the atmosphere gets thinner and thinner
the higher you go up but how much air
you require for an atmosphere to be
there means that the top will be in
different places the atmosphere stops
being breathable before you even get to
the top of the bottommost layer the
troposphere which is at about 10 km up
the air pressure is maybe a fifth what
it is at the surface here but there's
still plenty of air above the top of the
next layer the stratosphere is maybe 50
km up where the pressure is perhaps a
thousandth what it is at the surface but
by most definitions this is still far
from the top above the stratosphere
there's the mosphere and then the thir
thermosphere which starts at about 880
km above the surface the most common
definition for the top of the atmosphere
is in the thermosphere 100 km up at the
kman line but the thermosphere itself
extends way higher 600 km above the
surface in fact the ISS orbits in the
thermosphere 600 km up marks the start
of the exosphere the outermost layer of
the atmosphere where there are still
molecules of air but there aren't enough
of them to behave like a gas and that's
true up till about 10,000 km above the
surface where the solar wind finally
exerts more of a force on those
molecules than the Earth's gravity and
so they get Stripped Away into outer
space